come sorry
[Music]
a quarter of a century after its release
one piece continues to steer us on an
unforgettable Voyage charting the course
of Monkey D Luffy and the straw hat
Pirates to the Helm of the pirate world
and as the series continues to keep us
at the edge of our seats cheering the
straw hats as they defy yonko kaido in
the ongoing wano country Arc here's a
quick video recapping the most memorable
and impactful One-Shots in the series so
far all hands on deck for this one is
the top 10 One Piece One shots brought
to you by Vinnie tube
[Music]
and number 10 we travel back in time to
Brooke's introduction Arc
[Music]
Ade
thank you
the oldest member of the straw hats
Brook is capable when he's not being
goofy he's also an underrated character
I mean let's not forget his deadly
assault on black Mario's underlings in
wano all of whom he cut down in a single
stroke however his one shot one kill
antaron stands out not just for his
sword play but for the importance of the
information he unearths that moria's
zombie army can be vanquished with salt
this eventually turns the tide of the
battle to the straw Hat's favor
[Music]
next up at number 9 is the newest
addition to the straw hats crew the
formidable Knight of the sea jinbei as
he leaves the pompous Gekko Moria
dumbstruck with a single blow
we probably remember the fish man best
for his death-defying willpower and
courage when facing big mom's Soul
extraction ability but this early
example of his Supremacy at the
apocalyptic Summit war of marine foot is
equally memorable ahead of his fight
against jinbei Moria gains power and
size by devouring the shadows of several
Marines with the ability of his shadow
shadow devil from getting ahead of
himself Moria prepares to take Jin base
Shadow 2 but borrowed strength can only
amount to so much jinbei's Mastery of
fish man karate is always a Marvel to
watch as we see him cut moria's
self-satisfied dribble short
oh
at number eight is the one shot that got
tongues wagging Luffy Bringing Down the
giant 100 din at the corrida Coliseum
interest roster
[Music]
man
Don Quixote doflamingo holds a
Gladiators contest with the prize being
the flame flame fruit previously owned
by Ace naturally though Luffy joins the
tournament to claim his late brother's
devil fruit in characteristic nutty
fashion he enters the arena in Disguise
as the white bearded Lucy the people's
favorite one of his most fearsome
opponents is hajiruddin the Giant from
elbaf isn't one to be made light of as
Lucy finds out after his trusted Mount
brutal pool is brought to ground with
just one smack well Plucky as ever Luffy
swiftly knocks out the Colossus with
just the hockey enhanced gear second
punch although this is but a tiny
incident in the larger dress Ross's
story Luffy's one shot takedown of Honda
then has passed the test of time for a
hero's mind-boggling boldness of course
for one who aims to be the next pirate
king power is a must but the kindness
with which Luffy exact's revenge for
brutal ball is a rare quality to come by
and we can't help but love him for it
imagine a prehistoric elephant the size
of an island with legs long enough to
walk the seas in a trunk that can
decimate an entire fleet well that's
zunisha a champion at number seven as
she smashes the Beast Pirate's Jack in
his Fleet to Smithereens with just a
shake of a massive trunk
foreign
[Music]
a tribe that lives on the island of Zone
located on the ancient elephant's back
this counter-attack is most satisfying
besides the awesome action the existence
of zunisha before that unnoticed even by
the Minx makes the mystery surrounding
the background of the one-piece story
even more enticing what's more though
The Uncanny ability with which zunisha
communicates the momonosuke and Luffy
and ask them for permission to attack
Jack just adds to the Enigma this
ability called the voice of all things
is a super rare power akin to telepathy
and heard by only a handful of
individuals one of them being the pirate
king Roger himself this ramps up the
tension for what's in store for Luffy
and Momo later in the story
in the sixth spot Luffy's a force of
nature as he One-Shots a pacifista to
announce his return after the two-year
time skips
[Music]
thank you
during the time skip Luffy undergoes
rigorous training under Roger's first
mate Silver's Rayleigh and has a course
on haki drilled into him that means the
pacifista doesn't even stand a chance
against Luffy this one shot is important
not just for Luffy's display of his
newly acquired power but because it
introduces haki as the second major mode
of combat after devil fruits and since
then haki has emerged as the defining
factor in a match of strength between
formidable opponents we know for a fact
that Roger without a devil fruit was
strong enough to overwhelm whitebeard's
Tremor Tremor fruit considered the
strongest paramecia fruit as a first
look at the destructive potential of
Luffy's Armament haki his disposal of
the pacifist to pack some mean punch
Zorro knocks out scratchman Apple in a
battle between two members of the worst
generation at number five
no
[Music]
the stage is set by Queen as he
unleashes a deadly virus that turns
enemies and comrades alike into ice Oni
or ice demons before killing them in The
Madness of the ice only tag race that
ensues Zoro pursues our bull for the
antidote the endless Chase soon begins
to get on zoro's nerves who being the
solemn samurai warrior type is the exact
opposite of Queen and Apple with their
party sensibilities in the midst of the
Ruckus Zorro sees the seventh hand of a
comrade and that's when the real Oni is
Unleashed much to apu's Misfortune even
amongst the group of notorious Pirates
dubbed the worst generation Zorro along
with Luffy and Blackbeard are the most
terrifying as one of only two
non-captain members it's understandable
why people often mistake The
green-haired Swordsman for the captain
of the straw hats the Lightning Fast
slash on Apple is just the tip of the
iceberg in his element in the land of
the Samurai Zorro has already made kaido
bleed and is now up against King which
means that we can be sure to Feast our
eyes on some more of the good stuff
[Music]
thank you
featuring at number four is the most
epic use of observation haki in the
entire series
[Applause]
the Cowardly usob grows up exponentially
in the dressrosser arc as the
incapacitate sugar a senior officer of
the Don Quixote family not once but
twice now it's at that moment when he
awakens his observation haki and saves
Luffy and Trafalgar law that usop
finally lives onto the legacy of his
father yasob the sniper of the red hair
Pirates the impressive display of
sniping skills from the wacky
Sharpshooter can be credited for the
straw Hat's ultimate victory over Duffy
and his crew although we've seen Uso
pull through on a number of occasions in
the past for instance in his fight
against perona in the Thriller bark Arc
this Showcase of pure skill and power is
undoubtedly his finest moments so far
yet to see him play Amici role in wano
let's keep our hopes up for another God
usop moment
foreign
Pirates are most likely the only ones in
the new world who've built their
foundation on dreams and that's why high
up at number three is the memorable
fight between Luffy and Bellamy the
hyena in mock town
ridiculed and beaten up by Bellamy for
believing in the existence of skypier an
island in the sky Luffy chooses not to
defend himself in a moment that
nostalgically parallels Shanks his
refusal to fight a gang of mountain
bandits in marquino's bar all those
years ago however Luffy finally loses
his call when his Newfound friends are
hurt by Bellamy and his crew who only
believe in power and wealth playing the
role of the underdog perfectly Luffy
delivers the most Divine punch on
Bellamy's smug face knocking him
unconscious it's been a long journey
since this early incident but Luffy
hasn't changed at all still choosing to
fight for Pride dreams and friendship at
every turn this is apparent as he stands
firm before the yonko's kaido and big
mom in wano condemning their domineering
ways and challenging them to the crown
of the pirate king
oh
and that brings us to the runners-up
spot as Celestial Dragon Talos incurs
Luffy's wrath at the human auctioning
house in subodi
[Music]
[Applause]
Luffy's lifelong dream of becoming the
pirate king and obtaining the one piece
stems from his desire to be the freest
person in the world so when his mermaid
friend Kami is kidnapped and sold into
slavery and another friend the fish
Manhattan is shot by Charles it's not
hard to imagine what's gonna happen next
a furious Luffy bashes in the load some
Aristocrats face with utter disregard
for his exalted social status as a world
Noble Luffy's righteous Smackdown gives
him one hell of an introduction to
fellow supernova's law and kid who are
also present at the auction house we can
safely assume that their current
Alliance in wano is the most favorable
outcome of this past event
[Music]
so it's time to unveil the winner and
it's the big bad kaido singular
knockdown punch on Luffy in their first
meeting in wino
[Music]
lay me okay
right after blowing up an entire
mountain top with his blast breath the
Azure Dragon shows Luffy his place
despite being a drunken mess a recurrent
Victor in our top 10 videos we can't
have enough of this one shot takedown
with Luffy continuing his fight against
the yonko after recovering from the
powerful punch and miraculously
surviving a near-fatal fall as well
things have got a much more exciting
kaido happens to be the only bad guy on
the dispensing end in today's video he's
known as the strongest creature not just
for his physical attributes but for his
insatiable thirst for blood and combat
the fact that he relishes every assault
on his person and seemingly gets
stronger from it makes him a scary foe
we're glad that the yonko has finally
met his match in Luffy who after the
initial disappointment of being knocked
out cold in a single strike is showing
us his famous tenacity a pirate
acknowledged by Whitebeard himself and
allied with the equally terrifying big
mom kaido is definitely Luffy's ticket
into the big league more specifically
the club of the four Emperors of the sea
foreign
and that brings us to the end of today's
video don't forget to like subscribe and
turn on the notifications for more of
your favorite anime series and trending
topics and make sure you leave your
suggestions and thoughts on the video or
anything else in the comments below
until next time